of all the different witchcraft flavors
you know it's like a bag of Jolly
Ranchers the green and the purple and
the red and the white uh the the most
dangerous would seem to me to be the the
white witchcraft because it seems the
nicest so it seems the most palatable
and therefore but it's not it's not good
right it's not actually benign no
because all type of Witchcraft is bad
regardless of what you do you you read
tarot cards you go outside to speak to
Nature or do things in nature or you
think you're doing this for the universe
for whatever you are doing is bad why
because it's counterfeit because we have
the Holy Spirit and then in here you
have another spirit that is guiding that
experience so actually the question that
we should ask is like okay who is
guiding your experience this is the real
thing if it's not the Holy Spirit then
is another Spirit then is witchcraft new
age